you might expect those living on Prince
Charles Avenue to at least be curious
about the coronation but would its
residents in Derby really follow the
king's wish and Proclaim their loyalty
out loud it turns out they would
I swear that I will pay true allegiance
to your majesty and to your heirs and
successors according to the Lord so help
me God
some just get it quite patriotic to to
say it out loud and say allegiance to
the new king and yeah I think I mean
I'll be in my living room watching but
I'll probably say it on the day it does
have an odd thing but I think kind of
it's important to kind of keep
our kind of royal family and traditions
going so we should
be respect and thank him for
giving him the chance to
chair as a king
but for every loyal subject there are
others who find it hard I feel like
I don't know like
kind of like dictatorship like they've
got more power or things like that it's
like an oath isn't it
it's weird
the allegiance is one of several new
threads being woven into this ancient
ceremony and there are others that show
a clear push that the king is trying to
modernize the monarchy
the climax of the ceremony has arrived
it is 70 years since Queen Elizabeth was
crowned but at King Charles's coronation
female clergy and leaders of other
faiths will take part for the first time
how many of us get an opportunity like
this how often in a lifetime so of
course for me it'll feed into my own
story and my family's history but also
part of the nation's story and history
as it were and to be one of the first
female Bishops to take part in a
coronation is of course a very special
thing
that theme of inclusivity continued in
Hampshire where Personnel from across
the UK and the Commonwealth perfected
their processions seven thousand Sailors
soldiers and aviators will accompany the
king and queen to and from the
coronation
Lisa Dowd Sky News